I truly will never understand this mindset
that if you have a presence on social media
and you claim to be a traditional wife,
how that is synonymous with not being allowed to make money online,
which, news flash,
I don't make all that much that you probably think I do.
I make probably under 100.
That's on a good month.
I know when one hears the word tried wife,
it immediately brings up images of the 1950s,
but that's not at all what trad wife movement
and the trad wife trend is about.
Women since the beginning of time have worked in either domestic labor,
work in the. In their own home,
sometimes even outside of their own homes.
That's not like a new thing.
This is why the 1950s was such an interesting time,
because it was the first time that leisure was such a thing
that women didn't really have to make everybody's clothes.
You know, grow your own food and preserve it
and make sure everyone's warm come the winter.
It is a new era of leisure,
which is why we see that so many women were unhappy.
When you stop doing work in your lifetime,
then you're gonna start getting annoyed and going downhill
and just all these things.
We see that often when people retire and they just leave,
live a life of leisure
and not actually mentally stimulating themselves,
physically stimulating themselves.
So, yes, I do make a very small,
non substantial income.
Sometimes from social media.
Um, but this is a hobby to me.
I don't treat it as a career.
Cause this could all go away tomorrow,
and I'm still relying on my husband's income.